so to begin with straightforward
derivative you needed to know two rules
namely product and chain rule so the
product rule is the wolf you can even
see my view and my V there and this is
where I start you can see this my V you
- there's you and he comes V - but of
course to do V - you need chain rule
right so you can see this is really x
squared - 1 through the half you may
have rewritten that to help you keep in
your head book as you know I've done a
few of these before so that's why my
heart has come out the front x squared -
1 the power reduces okay so there's be
taking care of the outside function in
chain rule what's left after the outside
function the inside function which is x
squared - 1
it's derivative is just 2x very
conveniently that 1/2 and that's through
they cancel so here's my square root X
square minus 1 and there to be honest
I'd probably say okay fine really at
that point but let's just think about
this for a second usually when you
differentiate I mean you will get even
in the HSC level you'll get a handful of
questions if all they asked you to do is
just differentiate and at this point
you've used trade rule you've used
product rule you're done you probably
got to get 3 bucks at that point okay
but but suppose this is the function
right and it comes in the context that
more than just differentiate maybe you
have to maybe this function comes from
something else you've done or you have
to graph it or whatever okay so you can
see if I go forward I actually gain
insight because I can get this whole
thing on a single denominator right so
right up there in the numerator I can
factorize that guy I can work out where
its solutions are and that'll become
more important as you can see later on
so even though I would probably be happy
there for you guys there's no reason why
you can't go on and as you can see it's
quite easy to actually get them on a
common denominator because of the nature
of this guy and the denominator
all right so let's move forward I watch
them I'm going to be this so please tell
me I'm hundred eight point four three
yes no yes yeah okay good
so just to confirm in case you weren't
there right I pull out the first radio I
pull out the second gradient I launch
straight in through the ankle between
two lines but you'll notice I haven't
absolute value sign around this why is
that what does that have to know about
if it's negative if it's negative what
you're going to find will not be a first
quadrant angle because think right we're
trying to think of this kind of scenario
right or if you want to be a little more
sophisticated here's your stance right
so beam it you want that acute angle in
there that's why we usually have the
absolute value signs there so when I get
to this point that's 10 inverse of three
but that's the acute angle and the
question States second layer the
question tell me the obtuse angle okay
there was a question in the previous
exam I think which also caught you by
saying we want the angle between you
know sub-line and a particular direction
of the x axis maybe the negative
direction which is not the normal way so
again those are situations where you can
get as a two single exact value of 10
300 we've talked about this before
come on exam technique you want to get
there the quickest way what's the
quickest way you use your calculator it
you punch this in it gives you some -
1.73 blah blah blah garbage like I don't
know what that number is
so you square it you know you can square
it and get something nice because 300
degrees that's the related angles 60 so
you're gonna get the exact value right
so I recognize that as root 3 so that's
why I put that down straight away right
again
who got the tree at any first shot who
got it that's kind of good you recognize
it now okay excellent
+3 else if anyone's actually play like
proper place baseball get somebody good
throw a curveball or you don't being
country if you played cricket and you
bat it against someone who could do the
swing or out swing right the first time
you try and face that you're like what
just happened right you're like I swear
the ball is meant to be hung up and then
it was over there but the second time
you think hold on okay I've seen this
fight before I see what he's doing with
his hand now you look at this right let
me tell you why this is a successful
curveball right and therefore by knowing
how it why it's successful how to watch
out from next time okay
you think the first line what's your
immediate instinct what do you think you
you have to get expansion in other words
you are thinking algebraically it's
nothing there's no problem with that you
should see the differences square so off
you go
right now when you see this line again
what are you thinking you're thinking
Pythagorean identity because you see
square you're thinking trees no problem
is so far and when you get to here you
see a square root and you see a square
right so you think no problems I'm doing
trig I'm doing algebra that's just tan
but it's not just him all right
because the reason why the curveball
works is because I've you don't have
magicians they do misdirection it's like
they do something with this hand to make
you forget I'm doing something to go
over here this is it doesn't look like
an absolute value question does it
doesn't look like has anything to do
with absolute value but it does because
by definition in the first lesson that I
taught you I'm absolute value when you
square something and then you take its
square root you lose the sign right so
the square root of 10 squared a is not
10 it because 10 a what there is saying
it could be negative all right but the
square root of 10 squared a you can't
anyway get a negative out of that that's
why you have the absolute value days